BY RUSSELL WESTBROOK WHO IS WITH
US NOW FROM CAPITAL ONE ARENA.
RUSS, THANK YOU FOR TAKING A
COUPLE OF MINUTES WITH US.
HEY, ALWAYS A GOOD SIGN WHEN
YOUR LEAD IS SO BIG THAT YOU CAN
THROW THE SHOES TO THE CROWD
WITH 4:30 TO GO, HUH?
>> WELL, IS IT THE BEST FEELING,
AND I HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO DO
IT IN A WHILE, AND SOY ENJOYED
IT TONIGHT.
>> AND LOOKING AT THE SEASON,
AND AT ONE POINT, YOU WERE
17-32, AND THEN 17-6, AND YOU
ARE GOING TO WORK YOUR WAY INTO
THE TOURNAMENT, AND NOW INTO THE
PLAYOFFS, AND WHAT DID THEY TELL
YOU ABOUT WHAT THIS TEAM IS MADE
OF?
>> WELL, RESILIENCY, MAN.
WE HAVE A LOT OF THE GUYS IN
LOCKER ROOM, AND WE HAVE BEEN
THROUGH SO MUCH, COVID,
INJURIES, AND WE STUCK WITH IT.
WE HAVE HAD A TIME IN THE SEASON
WHEN WE COULD HAVE QUIT, BUT THE
GUYS IN THE LOCKER ROOM DIDN'T
DO IT.
THEY DID AN AMAZING JOB TO
STICKING TO IT, AND WHAT WE
KNOW, AND PUT OURSELVES TO BE IN
THE PLAYOFFS.
>> AND RUSS, THIS IS SHAQ, AND
GOOD PLAYER NEVER HAVE TWO BAD
GAMES IN A ROW.
AND FOR THE LAST GAME, YOU
DIDN'T PLAY THE BEST GAME, AND
IT HAPPENS TO THE BEST OF US,
AND WHAT WAS YOUR MENTALITY
COMING INTO THE GAME?
>> WELL, IN BOSTON I WAS
TERRIBLE AND I LET MY TEAMMATES
DOWN AND I KNEW IT.
I WANTED TO COME IN TO SET THE
TONE, AND I KNEW THAT WHAT I DO,
REBOUNDING AND PASSING AND
SCORING AND PASSING AND TONIGHT,
I DID THAT.
>> RUSS, BETWEEN THE COVID,
INJURIES AND THINGS LIKE THAT,
YOU GUYS HAVE, YOU KNOW, NOT
JUST YOU GUYS, BUT THE WHOLE
NBA, YOU GUYS ARE FINALLY QUOTE,
UNQUOTE HEALTHY, AND YOU THINK
THAT WE HAVE SEEN THE BEST
VERSION OF THE WIZARDS?
>> I THINK THAT WE JUST KIND OF
ARE GETTING STARTED.
WE HAVE SOME GUYS OUT, AND YOU
KNOW, WE HAVE SOME GUYS OUT, BUT
WE HAVE SOME TOUGH GUYS IN THE
LOCKER ROOM THAT, I BELIEVE IN
WITH EVERYTHING THAT WE HAVE,
AND SO HOPEFULLY WE CAN SHOCK
THE WORLD, AND TAKE IT ONE GAME
AT A TIME, AND GO TAKE CARE OF
PHILLY AND BUSINESS.
>> RUSS, CONGRATULATIONS WITH
THE FEAT OF THE TRIPLE-DOUBLES
AND ONE THAT NONE OF US THOUGHT
WOULD BE BROKEN, BUT
CONGRATULATION.
I HAD A CANDID CONVERSATION OVER
THE WEEKEND WITH MICHAEL JORDAN,
AND WE WERE DEBATING WHAT IS THE
HARDEST PART OF GETTING THE
TRIPLE-DOUBLE FOR RUSSELL
WESTBROOK, AND WHAT WOULD BE THE
HARDEST PART OF GETTING THE
TRIPLE-DOUBLE?
>> THE HARDEST PART IS WHAT YOU
CANNOT CONTROL IS THE ASSISTS.
>> THAT IS WHAT HE SAID!
>> I CAN'T CONTROL IF THE GUYS
MAKE THE SHOTS, AND I CAN MAKE
IT EASY FOR THEM, AND I CAN'T
CONTROL IF THEY MAKE IT OR NOT,
AND I CAN REBOUND ON MY OWN, AND
SCORE ON MY OWN, BUT I CAN'T
CONTROL IF THEY MAKE IT.
>> AND ONE MORE?
>> ON THE FANDUEL, KENNY AND I
BOTH SAID THAT YOU WERE GOING TO
HAVE A TRIPLE-DOUBLE, AND I
WANTED TO THANK YOU BOTH FOR
LETTING US DOWN.
>> MY BAD.
I WILL BE BETTER NEXT GAME, AND
I WILL TRY TO DO MY JOB.
MY BAD.
>> RUSS, YOU GOT TIME FOR FIVE
MORE FROM SHAQ?
>> ABSOLUTELY.